a gig on Game of Thrones is a proven
career enhancer but the show's actors
didn't materialize out of thin air
most of them had careers prior to
finding their way to the Seven Kingdoms
and not everything they worked on was
what you'd consider HBO level material
for your amusement and their chagrin
here our early roles of Thrones cast
members during the pregame era Emilia
Clarke before she was an international
superstar as Daenerys Targaryen Emilia
Clarke had virtually no on-camera
experience as an actress she's been on
one episode of the UK show doctors and
one sci-fi original movie fortunately
that movie
Triassic attack from 2010 provided her
with the opportunity to say well I guess
I do have experience working with giant
reptilian beasts and that takes you
surprisingly far in the world of Game of
Thrones Lena Headey ironically Cersei
Lannister actress Lena Headey 'he's
first performance for american
television was in the last outing of
Richard Dean Anderson as the one and
only MacGyver
in this TV movie from 1994 he D plays
Elise Morin whose father is killed that
sets a series of spine-tingling events
into motion which find MacGyver doing
what he does best
saving the day when the odds are against
him he DS character survives and ends up
on screen at the very end that means she
has the honor of being the last person
to share a conversation with MacGyver
why that's almost as impressive as being
queen of Westeros Alfie Allen when the
opportunity arises to take the spotlight
there's only one thing to do take it and
run that's when Alfie Allen better known
as Theon Greyjoy
does in the 2004 sequel to agent Cody
Banks in the scene the student orchestra
playing in front Queen Elizabeth and
visiting heads of state has to kill time
to prevent the g7 summit meeting from
starting when the call goes out to
improvise Allen's challenge to go for it
so he struts over to the microphone
slips on a headband and launches into a
German accented version of Edwin Starr's
war see for yourself
Conleth Hill
if you thought playing a character whose
main character tree includes a lack of
private parts was emasculating you
should talk to actor Kong with Hill he
plays Varys the spider on Game of
Thrones and in 2008 the veteran actor
also played an old bedridden lady in the
British reality show spoof Briggs got
the pop factor and possibly a new
celebrity Jesus Christ soapstar
superstar strictly on ice yes that's the
actual title Jonathan Pryce character
actor Jonathan Pryce has been working
for so many years that it almost seems
unfair to dig through his catalogue in
search of something embarrassing instead
let's spotlight a project relatively few
Americans know about his turn as the
master that's right we mean the
long-lived Doctor Who villain but it's
not an incarnation you would have seen
battling doctors 9 10 11 or 12 no price
found himself doing battle against Rowan
Mr Bean Atkinson yes in a very special
Doctor Who serial made for comic relief
Atkinson played the doctor
and when toe-to-toe with price before he
hung up his weird jacket and became the
high Sparrow we loved to hate on Game of
Thrones
and yes we know all about Shay and her
grown-up film career before being cast
on Game of Thrones you'll have to leave
youtube to learn more about that one
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which early role
of these Game of Thrones actors
surprised you the most